wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
hier ist noch meine handynummer ist das
eine 27
das ist eine 70 17 93 76 34 29 58 01 73
90 76 34 29 58 nicht so gut nicht so gut
warum nicht so gut meine tasche meine
meine tasche tasche verloren
ok moment du hast deine tasche verließ
das passiert hallo hallo wer bist du
denn
entschuldigung ich bin nicht nico in
mein name ist die st nico spricht nicht
so gut deutsch er seine tasche weltesche
ist schwarz und sie hat ein aufnäher mit
einem fahrrad
okay findet dann gebt sie würde bei der
polizeistelle ost ab die ist nur
schreiner straße 144 einer straße 144
mein schreiner straße mit rs chr und die
hausnummer ist die 144
danke euch viel glück
es ist eine entschuldigung